no one expected donald trump supporters
to go
quietly but the crowding of vote
counting locations
echoing his message to stop the process
is a reflection of where america is
right now
it's also a reflection of a race that
seems to be slipping away from the
president
he tweeted his encouragement to those
supporters his campaign continues
without any concrete evidence to try to
cast doubt on what's happening
we firmly believe that there are many
voters
in this group of mail-in people that are
not
proper voters in the last many days
we have received reports of many
irregularities
across the valley i went to vote and was
told i already voted
i pursued the matter and in years past i
always voted in person
this time they mailed out the ballot and
somebody
took my ballot joe biden continues to
preach a message of patience
but also confidence about where this is
heading i'm not here to declare that
we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners we
have to stop treating
our opponents as enemies we are not
enemies what brings us together as
americans
is so much stronger than anything that
can tear us apart
it is the counts in a handful of states
and outstanding votes from around
america's big cities
that will be decisive those states say
they're abiding by the law
these are people are not involved in
voter fraud
these people are not involved in voter
suppression i'm telling you they're
doing
their jobs every day it is hard and we
are thankful to them for it and we're
going to work with them to make sure
that every legal
lawful ballot is counted the set they
built for a joe biden victory rally is
still here and his campaign is very
confident that
at some point he will step out and stand
at that podium
as the president-elect but they know as
we've all learned in the last four years
that american politics is a very
unpredictable place right now
and on the streets we continue to see
the sort of dissatisfaction that's hung
over this country for months
they and the world are waiting for some
certainty
greg milam sky news wilmington in
delaware